esports has a massive audience but in
2022 it's getting tougher to do business
it turns out the broadcasts of games
while wildly popular just don't bring in
enough revenue for teams
twitch and youtube are still the only
platforms interested in esports content
which creates a lack of viewership
competition
talent is also getting increasingly
expensive for example players of the
up-and-coming game valorent are able to
demand as much as 30 thousand dollars a
month
teams are also constrained and that they
don't own the intellectual property of
the games they compete in
you can compare it to something in
traditional sports where
no one owns the idea of baseball no one
owns the idea of football but in esports
a publisher owns call of duty a
publisher owns overwatch or league of
legends
and so that means that if a team wants
to sell an item in the game
they have to have the consent of that
publisher this is leading teams to
diversify their revenue streams as a way
to scale up
alternatives include producing media
content software and tech lifestyle and
merchandising or promoting physical
products there's also nfts web 3
blockchain technology and the metaverse
and sponsorship deals can also be quite
lucrative with the right partner tsm
struck a team naming rights deal with
ftx for 210 million dollars over 10
years for context the naming rights deal
that the miami heat signed with ftx for
their arena last year is for 135 million
over 19 years here's a look at which
teams made the top five of our list of
most valuable esports companies this
year at number five is cloud nine with a
valuation of 380 million dollars the
santa monica-based company is returning
to competition in counter-strike global
offensive but they're diversifying with
new lines of business via training
grounds a coaching app and stratis a
subscription service for super fans at
number 4 is faze clan with a valuation
of 400 million dollars
the company has revealed it planned to
go public through a spac merger last
october claiming it was already worth
650 million dollars and would reach 1
billion with the money it raised in the
deal but a recently disclosed agreement
with partner snoop dogg suggests the
company may be lowering its own
valuation at number three is team liquid
with a valuation of 440 million dollars
the company which has offices in both
los angeles and the netherlands is
diversifying in several directions at
once the company launched the community
initiative liquid plus last year and has
a video content production arm as well
as an influencer management agency at
number two is 100 thieves with a
valuation of 460 million dollars
no team in the forbes esports ranking
has appreciated more than 100 thieves on
the 2020 list it was in fifth place with
190 million dollars
the company which is developing a
lifestyle brand at the intersection of
apparel entertainment and esports
announced a 60 million dollar
fundraising round last december that was
two months after it made its first
acquisition buying the gaming keyboard
brand high ground and at the top of this
year's list is tsm with a valuation of
540 million dollars as mentioned earlier
the company has a 10-year 210 million
dollar naming rights deal with crypto
exchange ftx but tsm's real selling
point is its tech business blitz an app
that trains users in popular games and
dyno which offers a moderation bot for
discord servers
some around the industry have expressed
wariness about the company's leadership
with ceo andy dinh accused late last
year of bullying the company says it has
hired an independent investigator and
claims din has recused himself from the
investigation
you